now us see in real time what happens to
children when they don't have a strong
Father Figure in their life Kim
Kardashian was still given primary
custody even though she is essentially a
sex worker this is a sex worker why and
I know you guys want to say Kanye is
crazy whatever but why are we assuming
that Kim Kardashian is more stable than
Kanye he has father's custody and what
you saw was is now we see North really
having a public childhood before her
eyes but is not healthy for a child
especially a young girl being overloaded
on attention from a young age it's going
to lead to issues later and Kanye
expressed his desire to want his
children to live a normal life and now
you see a video of Kim coming out
talking about how North actually prefers
to be at her dad's house because there
aren't all these strangers in their home